this afternoon we also have an exciting
announcement to ensure former inmates
can overcome some of the greatest
barriers to employment including limited
access to transportation which is needed
for interviews and for jobs to make this
announcement I'd like to invite up a
very special guest and a powerful
advocate for not only justice reform but
just a good person and I hear she's
starting to study law she's also one of
the most successful people in the
entertainment business soon she'll be
one of the most successful lawyers I
hate to tell all my lawyers back there
but I knew it I knew her father and I'd
say she's got good genes that I can tell
you good genes for everything and she's
been a real friend and her husband has
been a real friend of mine Kim
kardashian-west
hi it really is such an honor to be here
today so thank you my whole journey with
criminal justice reform started about a
year ago when I came to see the
president after speaking to Ivanka and
Jared who really fought for me to get
here and I pled the case of Alice
Johnson who the president granted
clemency to and after that I really
spent so much time going to different
prisons because I really had no
connection to anybody on the inside and
really just felt like for me I I'm at
the place in my life that I wanted to
make a difference and just wanted to do
the right thing but I didn't know how or
what to do or even really what was going
on and so after going to visit so many
different prisons and really sitting
down with lifers with every situation
you can possibly imagine my heart just
completely opened up and I wanted to do
more so I started to study the law which
is you know law school basically in
California and my attorneys are here
today Aaron and Jessica from cut 50 they
thank you
the best part of it is I learned so much
that I don't even know if I don't want
to speak for anybody in law school but I
learned so much just basically working
on memos and being the assistant to them
while the first-step Act was happening
and like learning how you get bills
passed and working on it from the ground
up so to get the president's support and
to see it come to fruition was magic and
the one thing that I just realized that
needed so much support that I'm happy to
help and be supportive where I can was
the reentry of people coming home and
seeing the lack of support that really
existed whether it's housing or the
amount of letters that I get with people
just needing transportation to job
interviews to jobs these people want to
work they want the best outcome and I'm
so happy to be here today amongst people
that want the same thing and that really
believe in supporting their reentry so
I'm so happy to announce today that we
have a rideshare partnership where
formerly incarcerated people will be
gifted gift cards so that they can get
rides to and from job interviews to and
from jobs family members and that is so
important so needed and I just want to
thank the president for really standing
behind this issue and seeing the
compassion that he's had for criminal
justice has been really remarkable so I
just want to thank all of the
organizations that are you know
partnering with everything that's going
on and really being supportive because
it really does mean a lot just so many
people that I've had the pleasure to
speak to and I think
the ultimate goal is everyone wants the
community to be safe and the more
opportunity we have and that they have
and the support that we help give them
the safer everyone will be in the
recidivism rate will be continued to
just get lower and so I'm just thankful
to everyone here that's in support and
so proud of this partnership with the
rideshare organization
thank you
thank you
I think she's pretty popular huh I can
tell you this if she is your assistant
she's your assistant two lawyers she's
your sister she's the highest-paid
assistant Ingres has never been anything
like it anyway Thank You Kim that was
beautiful